they always say things like [__] your
feelings but my argument is if we know
women are designed to have more
emotional intelligence we produce more
estrogen we produce more oxytocin we
actually by Design more emotional why
would that be an insult it's like saying
to somebody oh you're disabled [__] your
legs like no you're designed that way
why is that used as an insult to women I
mean I think he's just talking about
like a lot of times women think their
feelings are reality so girls on the
girls on the show will come on the show
and say this is like this is how the
world is because of how I feel basically
but that is her reality because that's
how she's designed by biology that's not
what's true
so for so for example we could talk
about the pay Gap women could feel like
we make less than men but he would say
something like [__] your feelings yeah
and so that that's the context that he's
using it in that context it makes sense
because his page graph is just not true
but in general we have innate mechanisms
to make us feel more anxious than a
situation is that's why we're mothers
why we get why we're so good at being
mothers is because we sent danger when
it's not there we think our baby's being
left alone or we've got to go right
we're designed by that and if we weren't
but we're governed by our feelings we'd
both be like okay baby the sleep don't
need to check on it but biologically
we're designed to be more feeling based
it's what makes women beautiful which is
not an insult and he uses it as an
insult I don't think he's using it as an
insult I don't think he's just saying it
doesn't work in a debate when you're
talking about it it works in in a
discourse if you're going to communicate
to women and men are going to community
to communicate with women that if they
don't recognize that women exercise
feelings and women don't recognize men
exercise logic they'll never be
compatible
I think he knows that women act through
it but okay like this is an example of
you as a woman telling men how they need
to talk to us and it's like they're
trying to do your strategy you're trying
to dictate like how men need to say
things but that's not how men do things
men talk how they talk and so it's like
why would I go to a man and say you have
to talk like a woman like you're
feminist if I'm a man and if I've got a
son as well I know have to speak to him
from a place of logic for him to
understand it he won't understand if I
talk to him entirely emotionally so if
you come to me as a man with a problem I
will say me and Nathaniel talk all the
time and I'll say I'll give him
practical advice because he's a man and
I speak his language he will give me a
more emotional advice because he
recognizes I'm a woman that's how we
have intelligent distance
yeah that seems quite that seems like
quite strong
experience like this exactly but that's
how healthy discourse is you know I have
this problem and this isn't this isn't a
you thing it's just like a thing I hate
it when people come on and tell me how
to talk on my podcast it's like if you
were so good at it then you would do it
and you would make it bigger and so it's
like how are you going to go to them and
say oh I know how to talk no no you
don't know how to talk it's just me yeah
you know I'm talking about in this
example for fresh and fit yeah because
I've been in this situation I've been in
this situation where like a girl will
say I don't like the way you like
they'll be like oh I don't like the way
she does this I don't like this I don't
like what like whatever it is and I my
my first thought is like how delusional
are you if you could do it better you
would because it's not about doing it
better it's about offering an
alternative perspective I don't care to
do it better than Marlon or no but but
my point is my point is they know what
they're doing
or read the book of Seduction they talk
a little bit about this okay okay right
where they say
um let's say for instance
um my woman comes to me with a problem
yeah and I'm just going to give you a
logical solution because that's what
makes sense to me right when really it
doesn't land anything why don't you just
go why don't you quit your job then it's
making you unhappy it's like you want to
you want to vent you want me to show
some empathy that kind of vibe when
you're when a woman comes to a man with
the with the issue it's it's it's the
same it's the similar kind of thing
because she's expecting something from
him where it's like you know why are you
showing empathy why aren't you
understanding but he's just thinking I
see the logic in this it should be a
quick quick it can be it's like algebra
we want it simplified straight away and
it's like that's kind of the disconnect
so it's quite it's quite rare not rare
but it's it's nice where obviously when
we have the conversation like you kind
of I understand how you would need it
um received and you understand how like
and that's how we communicate and that's
how we have this friendship for so long
and that's what I want to teach people
rather than women and there's men are
that because you don't learn how to use
those skills to practically apply and
create a healthy relationship and if we
have this platform we should use the
blessing of it to improve lives rather
than divide people but they do improve
lives that's the thing like they they do
all this stuff people are now they do
okay they do okay okay Meg Tower is a
whole nother that's a whole nother group
fashion fit aren't mgtow they do they do
Improvement for men there's men that
have called in on their show and said
they that they they didn't commit they
didn't commit suicide so they are
helping mgtow those are men that were
walking away until the laws change and I
understand that they want to walk away
from marriage and relationships until
the laws change I understand where
they're coming from I get that but it's
um not constructive to society if we
want to create homes and we want to
create two parent households me watching
a bunch of feminists or him watching a
bunch of red pills we are going to come
back with negativity towards each other
whereas if we take those platforms and
teach people how to communicate
effectively and create a home we are
doing more of a service to society could
I um disagree with that
so I think that um
anything that just makes people chat and
think is good and it would automatically
come to like a good conclusion anyway I
think that's the shrooms
no I just think absolutely I think your
points are extremely valid but I think
part of the issue is that we're told a
lot especially as men to change our word
and change our dialect change appealing
to how women feel more so than we are
about how many times
I'm not talking about I'm talking about
um as opposed to saying like you've said
oh men approach things more logically so
it's more of a push towards understand
her first before understanding him which
doesn't give the unity that you're
afterwards like for example I have five
sisters I have a lot of sisters and my
mom has to explain to them that he I
don't process things like they process
things if they get emotional about
things next week they'll be fine the
week after they'll be up again and
they're like you're expecting him to
jump on with your emotions
it's hard for them to understand and
wherever I've been told to you know
respect their feelings and understand
they think differently as well in the in
the world it's more that side of it it's
not like okay look this guy's gonna
think differently from you it's just
more accommodate to her because she
feels a certain way and that's not what
was that's that's the divide that right
I had I had a homemaker so we're opening
um guys go subscribe to what the wife
School Channel it should be in the
description
um get us to a thousand Subs anyway
um we're doing a wave score and I and
I'm I'm I've been talking to different
like wives and homemakers that are going
to teach different like classes for it's
going to be fun and one of them
literally said she she teaches women
like [__] your feelings it's not about
your like this is something she a
homemaker of 30 years teaches women [__]
your feelings it does not matter how you
feel yeah and and so it's like when the
women say it it's okay but the men yeah
no I agree that you can't make uh
decisions on emotions but emotions can't
be entirely ignored because it's how
we're designed if I teach a man [__] a
woman's feelings what kind of father
will he be
how will he raise a daughter I don't
know my dad that's kind of how he but
what kind of father are you those guys
are in the comments saying [__] feelings
[__] women what kind of father are you
planning to become it's just it's not
even that it's more just like how happy
are you but that's the context of a
debate again that's in the context of it
if it leaves yourself
contextual what if it leaves your mouth
it's in your soul like if I say [__] men
men are trash even if it's in the
context of a debate it's in myself no no
but again like this is context like he's
saying [__] your feet like your feelings
don't you can't your feelings are not
like what do they say facts over
feelings
that's all right but do you did you see
when they there was a fight that broke
up when a guy and a girl they hit each
other and stuff I saw one clip of that
yeah there's a clip on fresh and fit and
there was a guest and a girl next to him
and they got into a physical fight the
guy started hitting the girl the girl
started hitting the guy I think they
both eat each other and yeah yeah that
does not filming and then I only know it
because I watch Adam's sauce cast and he
who I love he um spoke about it he had
them on a set and he had one of the
girls that was in the set and she said
oh I just felt really unsafe in that
moment and Marlon was like [__] your
feelings because she wasn't in any
danger what is it it's uh Myron Myron
okay [__] his name
no I actually don't mind him I just
think it's uh you know it is what he is
I think it's just communicating
effectively in it yeah you know I mean
if you want to communicate quicker and
effectively it will it was nice to just
know the shortcut okay cool she's not
gonna take how I'll speak to the guys
about it she's gonna react this way if I
if I do it this way and and obviously
you know if if you're on the alpha in a
situation you can kind of force your way
force your way so like you you can say
[__] your feelings and maybe she'll just
shop but are you really resonating is
she really understanding or she's just
shutting up because she doesn't are you
actually creating a relationship in that
moment so I so when you said the thing
about you know their daughters that is
the one that is one of the things where
I had to really think all right I have
to learn how to communicate on that
level because
I just think of my mom versus my dad
like my dad really
it's not about like he he kind of does
that with me I mean not in like a rude
way but like if I go to my mom like I
always say I go to my mom if I wanted to
cry about something if I go to my dad I
want a solution like I just think men
and women communicate in different ways
and we have as women no business
policing men at telling them how to
communicate why because if we did it to
you guys because but if somebody said it
to us it would be beneficial again no no
but they don't take it
don't get it twisted like I still will
probably want to give the the solution
right but if you understand that what
they need is the emotional response you
get your solution out of it you can get
you can do it in a way where you still
get the same Solutions I mean I think
it's about just the knowledge of knowing
that person is going to receive it like
this if you yeah but then that depends
on the level of their emotional response
which is why it ends up coming to just
[__] feelings because you have to
take all of that out of it for you to
really understand what's going on but
[__] your feelings won't make a woman
abide by you and sub-summit to you when
you say that of course not because if
you don't go crazy counterproductive you
just don't say [__] feelings you
can't do it in a different way like hey
oh listen take that emotion put to the
side pin that let's come back to that
Leo yeah I just as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible